it's all nonsense we all we know it's
all nonsense but it continues at the
highest levels of government here is
assistant secretary for health rachel
levine and she wants to do weird [ __ ]
kids so we really want to to to base our
treatment and uh and to
affirm and to
uh support and empower these youth not
to limit their participation in
activities in sports and even uh limit
their ability to get gender affirmation
treatment in their state
all right so that gal was a dude for
about 45 years of her life i think
married to a woman has kids blah blah
blah
decides to transition or whatever's
going on there
that's fine with me as an adult like you
can do whatever you want uh what's
dangerous about that is what
he she whatever said at the end which is
that they she basically he she wants to
put these kids on puberty blockers you
know in other countries if this was
happening in the middle east and they
were like oh we're going to chop off
kids genitals and we're going to all of
this stuff people would not be that
thrilled about it right people would not
be that thrilled and then it would be
the left calling those people
islamophobes or something um but it's
just nonsense like that is health
disinformation right they talk about
misinformation all the time if you are
interested in just affirming what a
seven-year-old says i'm a girl today and
you're like oh you are a girl and i'm
gonna drug you
you are insane you are legitimately
crazy and you should be studied at an
institute in sweden probably that's what
we should be doing with you people